what I want to do in this video is
review a little bit of what we've
learned about monopolies and in the
process get a better understanding for
some of the graphical representations
which we have talked about in the past
but I want to put it all together in
this video here so let's say that the
industry that we are in the demand curve
looks something like that so that is
demand and I'm going to assume that it
is a linear demand curve this axis right
over here is dollars per unit in the
context of demand that's price and this
is quantity over here this little graph
here we still have quantity in the
horizontal axis but the vertical axis
isn't just dollars per unit it's
absolute level of dollars so over here
we can actually plot we can actually
plot total revenue as a function of
quantity total revenue so obviously if
we remember we're assuming we're the
only producer here where we have a
monopoly we have a monopoly in this
market so if we pick a quantity if we
pick if we don't produce anything we're
not going to generate any revenue so our
total revenue will be zero and if we
produce a bunch but we don't charge
anything for it and that's this point
right over here our total revenue will
also will also be zero and we've done
this in other videos but then as we
increase quantity from this point our
total revenue will keep going up and up
and up there'll be some maximum point
and then it'll start going down again so
our total revenue would look something
like this total revenue would look
something like that total revenue and
from the total revenue we can think
about what the marginal revenue would
look like remember the marginal revenue
just says if I increase my quantity by a
little bit how much am i increasing my
total revenue and so that's essentially
the slope the slope of the total revenue
curve at any given point or you could
think of it as the slope of the tangent
line and we've seen before when you
start here you have a very high positive
slope and we've seen in other videos it
actually ends up being the exact same
value is where the demand curve
intersects the vertical axis right over
there but then it keeps going lower the
slope it becomes a little less deep less
deep less steep is still positive less
deep less deep and then becomes e
go right over there and then it starts
going negative so it becomes zero right
at right at that quantity so it becomes
the larger the slope of this keeps going
down and down and down it's positive
then it becomes zero and then it
actually becomes negative and you see
that here now it starts downward sloping
even more steep even more steep and even
more steep so that's the revenue side of
things and let me label this this is our
marginal that's our marginal revenue
curve slope of the total revenue if
we're going to maximize profit we need
to think about what our costs look like
so let me draw our total cost curve and
I will do it in magenta so let's say our
total costs look something like this
total costs look something like that
out here when we have very few units we
have zero units all of our costs are
fixed costs and then we as we had
produce more and more units with the
variable costs start piling on over
there and even from this diagram you can
actually start to visually see economic
profit economic profit and when we talk
about when we're talking about costs and
profit in an economics class like this
is kind of one I guess you remember you
should view it in terms of economic
profit when we're talking about total
costs we're talking about opportunity
costs so this is total total opportunity
costs both the implicit the ones that
you or both the explicit the ones that
you're actually paying money for
explicitly and the implicit opportunity
cost total opportunity costs that's
total opportunity cost and the
difference between your total revenue so
for a given quantity for a given
quantity the distance the difference
between your total revenue and your
total opportunity costs that gives you
your economic profit so for this
quantity right over here your economic
profit would be represented by the
height of this little bar between these
two curves but what we see what's going
on is as we increase the quantity over
here these curves are getting further
and further apart that's because the
green curve the total revenue has a its
slope is larger than this purple curve
which is total total opportunity cost or
you could say total cost and so we could
even go even further along this the
distance between the two curves gets
bigger
Eggar looks like it maxes out right
about right around here someplace and
then the two things start getting closer
and closer together now this purple
curves slope is now larger than the
orange curve slope so then they start
getting closer and closer together
and so if you were to just look at this
graph whatever the maximum distance
between these two things are it looks
like it's about it looks like it's about
there right over here that would be your
maximum economic profit but we know we
can also visualize it on this curve over
here and we can do that by plotting our
marginal cost and remember marginal cost
just as marginal revenue is the slope of
your total revenue curve marginal cost
is the slope the instantaneous slope at
any point of your total cost curve so I
will do that let's do that in yellow so
right over here you have a zero slope or
pretty close to zero at least the way I
drew it over there so your marginal cost
is going to be pretty close to zero
right over there and then we see that
this slope keeps increasing and
increasing and increasing and so our
marginal cost will keep increasing
increasing and increasing so it will
look something like that
that is our marginal cost curve so if if
we pick a quantity and if we find that
the marginal cost over here I don't know
let's say it's five dollars per unit
that literally means that the slope at
that same quantity the slope of our
total cost curve that the slope over
there would have to be five that's what
that is telling us this is plotting the
slope of this curve right over here and
if we want to maximize profit we already
talked about how we would do it visually
on this curve we can do it over here
well right over here as we produce if we
start from producing nothing to
producing something for each incremental
unit our mark the incremental revenue we
get on that is much higher than the
incremental cost so hey we should
produce it because we're going to get
profit there we could keep producing
because we're going to get profit on
each of these incremental units so we'll
keep doing it we'll keep doing it we'll
keep doing it until the marginal revenue
is equal to the marginal cost at that
point it doesn't make sense for us to
produce any more if we produce an extra
unit past that point on that unit our
cost will be higher than our revenue so
it will eat into our economic
so this right over here is where we max
the quantity at which we maximize profit
and we see it we see it right over there
the way I drew it luckily it looks like
that is the maximum point between those
two curves as well and it makes sense
before at this point when marginal
revenue is higher than marginal cost
that means that the slope of the total
revenue curve is larger than the slope
of the total cost curve so they're
getting further and further apart after
this point F and right at that point
their slopes are the same so the slopes
are going to be the same right over
there and then after that point the
slope of the marginal cost curve or the
marginal cost is higher which tells that
the slope of the total cost curve is
higher then the slope of the total
return the total revenue curve and so
they're going to get closer and closer
together and this distance gets quenched
apart so that is where you maximize
profit and if you wanted to visualize
the actual profit on this graph over
here we cannot obviously visualize it
here is the distance between these two
curves if you want to visualize it over
here we would have to find we would have
to plot our average total cost curve and
essentially what you're doing is just
taking this total cost curve and you're
not just taking the slope at any point
that's the marginal cost instead you're
just dividing it by the quantity so if
you take this total cost curve if you
take this value divide it by very very
very low quantity you're going to get a
very very very very large number you
could imagine as you're spreading your
fixed costs amongst a very small
quantity so you can get a very large
number then as you produce more and more
and more your average total costs go
down but then your variable costs start
picking up and your average total cost
might look something like that average
total costs and so if you want to know
your profit your that which you have
maximized from this graph right over
here say well this is the quantity that
maximizes my profit marginal revenue is
equal to marginal cost the price that I
can get in the market for that quantity
well then you go up to your demand curve
and it gives you this is the price that
you will get for that quantity and so
that is on a on a per unit basis that is
the revenue that you will get you could
you can view price is equal to price is
the same thing as
revenue revenue per unit so on a per
unit basis this is the revenue you're
getting and on a per unit basis this is
your average cost this is average total
causes is taking all your costs and
dividing it by units so on an average
per unit basis this is going to be your
economic profit on a on a per unit basis
and if you wanted to find your actual
economic profit you would have to
multiply it by the total number of units
so you would essentially have the area
of this rectangle right over here this
is your per unit average economic profit
and show your total economic profit is
going to be quantity times profit per
unit and so this right over here is
economic economic profit or maybe I
should call total economic profit let me
write it out total total economic
economic profit and the area of that
rectangle should be the same thing as
the height as the height of this right
over here and the only reason and we can
maintain this is a sustainable scenario
because we have a monopoly no one else
can enter
if this was not a monopoly if there were
no barriers to entry then other people
say hey there's economic profit there
that means it's there's an incentive to
for me to put those same resources
together and try to compete because I'm
going to get better returns than my then
my opportunity costs would otherwise
that then might then my alternatives is
a good way to think about it